et face à cette crise mondiale des
carburants la quête d'autres formes
d'énergie est plus que jamais
d'actualité
à la réunion on pense à utiliser
l'énergie de la mer c'est la houle mais
aussi la température qui intéresse
l'énergie de la mer pour la récupérer il
existe déjà trois technologies en écosse
au portugal à la réunion les sites
potentiels sont identifiés tout autour
de l'île saint pierre pour récupérer
l'énergie des vagues saint-paul celle
des cours en salle nice 1-3 et le port
pour récupérer l'énergie thermique
c'est l'enjeu pour la réunion l'idée
serait d'établir des plateformes en
pleine mer qui récupèrerait l'eau froide
à 1000 mètres de profondeur une eau à 5°
qui produirait de l'énergie propre pour
larrère cette agence qui emploie une
quinzaine d'ingénieurs l'énergie des
mers c'est l'avenir non seulement pour
la réunion mais aussi pour toutes les
îles tropicales on peut utiliser le
froid qui est sous l'eau pour faire la
climatisation mais également pour
fabriquer de l'électricité
l'enjeu pour les îles tropicales de
cette technologie est le même que
l'enjeu de la fusion nucléaire pour les
continents sauf que à la différence de
fusion nucléaire cette énergie est
complètement propre et éternel pérenne
deux études de faisabilité seront
bientôt lancés à saint-pierre et en baie
de saint paul
l'énergie thermique c'est à courte
échéance selon les membres de l'are r si
les travaux démarrer cette année
la réunion pourrait produire de
l'énergie propre et à grande échelle
dans cinq ans